hey everyone bandit here uh if you
didn't know the nintendo uh animal
crossing direct just happened this
morning and they decided to make it
decently early in the morning which is
why i am once again appearing before you
with coffee in hand not only did they go
over some really cool stuff that's
coming for animal crossing including a
huge free update and then paid dlc
coming uh very soon after they also gave
details on nintendo switch's online
expansion you know the one that was
going to include the nintendo 64 virtual
console as well as the sega genesis um
and now as well as the future paid
animal crossing dlc i just wanted to
give my thoughts
on that because it's it's uh it's kind
of like a roller coaster right now when
the nintendo 64 online was announced i
was up here sega genesis i was up here
talking about animal crossing i was up
here
and then they announced the pricing for
all this stuff and i'm no longer up
there i'm i don't know where i am right
now uh but i just wanted to kind of give
my thoughts to you guys and and and
talk with y'all a little bit about it
see where you guys stand on it so that i
kind of feel how my community feels one
second
a little bit of that kickstart juice so
for starters the nso expansion
pack is going to be 50 a year with the
family edition being 80 a year both of
these are obviously a hike up of the
pricing over the 20 a year uh which was
what nso has been this entire time now
the reason why i'm conflicted about this
pricing is that on the one hand we have
a 30 a year
increase to nso which is obviously just
a hard sell for anybody um but on the
other hand we have you know the other
gaming companies which everybody brings
up in the situation which for over a
decade has been charging people like me
either fifty dollars a year or sixty
dollars a year for the privilege of
playing online now these other game
companies tried to make that plan better
over the years and give players uh
aaa titles sometimes for free uh per
month you know stuff like that as a part
of like game passes and things like that
but let's call it what it is it is a 60
a year service for the privilege of
playing online with your friends now on
that note nintendo is not looping in
online gaming to this expansion you can
still stay at twenty dollars a month or
i'm sorry twenty dollars a year if you
just wanna play online with your friends
and you don't care about the nintendo
switch online or the sega genesis online
which a lot of people don't so there is
at least
that right the fact that it's optional
and you can even buy the animal crossing
dlc separately but on the other hand on
that note um if you do buy the if you're
planning on buying the animal crossing
dlc which is going to be 25
then for the first year of nso plus
expansion it includes the animal
crossing dlc which means that at least
for the first year it would only be
about five bucks extra you know if you
were to take that twenty five dollars
out of that extra thirty dollars so
for animal crossing fans this is just a
five dollar extra expansion for the
first year and that's about all the
positive stuff i can say about it uh
there are quite a few negative things as
well besides obviously hiking up the
price for games that are all well over
20 years old is uh
i'm not
super okay with that tactic as a
business i also
actually don't appreciate the fact that
animal crossing is looped into that
because on the flip side you know let's
say that somebody doesn't play animal
crossing and then they pay the extra 30
for the nso expansion pass well now
they're obligated to go buy animal
crossing you know the base game so that
they can enjoy this the more that you
just like connect games and the online
services and dlcs and you just kind of
mesh them all together the more you
force people to just go ahead and buy
absolutely everything that you're
selling which is
i mean is it a good tactic from a
business point of view yeah i mean yeah
of course it is i mean this is this is
like duh why wouldn't you do this
everybody's gonna buy everything but
from a consumer point of view this this
this kind of sucks man not gonna lie
um i would rather them just bring back
the virtual console and let people
purchase these games independently
that's what i would rather see them do i
would rather just purchase ocarina of
time on its own for i don't know five
six dollars however much they would
charge i don't know uh maybe not ten
dollars i might not purchase it for ten
dollars because you know again it's over
20 years old but you know i would rather
purchase these things separately than
being forced to pay 30 dollars extra a
month for the privilege of playing these
games not even for the privilege of
playing online or anything like that
just for the privilege of playing n64
and sega genesis online anyway i don't
know you guys i'm conflicted i'm kind of
i don't know it's a little bit of a
rollercoaster of emotions right now i'm
gonna have to think about it a little
bit to see if i'm going to go forward
with purchasing the service or if i'm
going to
not
and just find other ways to play the
games that i love but either way let me
know what you guys think in the comments
below and please let's not let's not
turn this into some sort of
anti-nintendo anti-other people who are
pro-nintendo fight in the comments okay
be civil people are going to have
different opinions on this be civil if
somebody is okay with paying that much
for it let them be okay with that okay
and vice versa anyway you guys be good
i'm gonna go back to working on some
other videos uh but you guys be good
i'll see y'all next time this is bandit
looking forward to seeing you all next
time okay signing out peace